[Music]
tell me about this new boy at the store
hey what's your favorite song in this
you don't know what love is i am not
answering that
is he cute i didn't really notice that
much
my band's playing nine or nine if you
want to come
never met a girl who knows much about
music as you do
and television don't get me started
we've seen every episode of everything
how was it he's extraordinary
[Music]
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here can i walk you
life's too short to waste time and
things you don't absolutely love
but how do you know if you love
something absolutely
i guess when it's the only thing that
matters
[Music]
the band got off of the gig in paris
come with us on tour
i'm afraid i can't but i think you very
well could be the next jungle train
what are you gonna be
[Music]
wnat television talking about the
assistant producer position
are you married yes hey
producer's assistant's not the best job
for a housewife
why should i hire you because i didn't
know that a negro woman television
producer even existed
and all my life that is all i've ever
wanted to be it's been a long
time since i felt the way
sylvie what are you doing in new york
recording an album
so good to see you you too it's been
awhile
you're working you're not being a very
good hostess and what will people say
i can't be the woman of your dreams
while also trying to be the woman of my
own
i guess i just wanted you to be happy
even if i couldn't be a part of your
life pleasant experiences ahead don't
[Music]
pacify
[Music]